foreign
and welcome to this new video on NLP
engineer salary with the word advancing
towards a more informed and database
future learning skills that help us to
be relevant in the job market is crucial
once at skill in the field of data and
AI is natural language processing let us
start by understanding what NLP is
natural language processing or NLP is a
branch of artificial intelligence or AI
that deals with understanding and
manipulating human language it seeks to
develop algorithms and systems that can
understand and process both structured
and unstructured language data to
support decision making processes NLP is
a field that has been gaining momentum
in recent years thanks to advance in
machine learning algorithms and the
availability of large data sets such as
social media conversations customer
reviews and medical records energy is
used in various applications such as
language translation sentiment analysis
Tech summarization and text generation
if you want to master NLP and become an
expert NLP engineer then you should
enroll an amazing Ai and machine
learning program by caltex ctme you will
gain skills like machine learning deep
learning reinforcement learning NLP
generative AI prompt engineering chart
GPT and more this Ai and machine
learning bootcamp includes live classes
delivered by industry experts Hands-On
Labs industrial relevant projects and
master classes by Caltech instructors so
hurry up what are you waiting for enroll
the course now find the course Link in
the description box so before we move
ahead consider subscribing to Simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from us so let's move
ahead by knowing what does NLP include
at its core NLP involves a series of
steps number one is pre-processing thing
the first step in NLP is to prepare the
language data for analysis this involves
activities such as cleaning tokenization
and normalization of the text Data Step
2 involves feature extraction the next
step is to extract relevant features
from the prepared data this involves
identifying keywords stems and parts of
speech tags that are important for the
task at hand step 3 involves model
training the extracted features are then
used to train a machine learning model
such as neural networks or a support
Vector machine to predict the target
variable and the last step is model
evaluation once the model is trained it
needs to be evaluated to ensure it
performs well on new data now let's move
ahead by knowing NLP job roles and
responsibilities several job roles that
involves NLP and each role is focused on
different aspects of NLB here are some
most common NLP job roads the number one
is NLP engineer this role involves
developing and implementing NLP
Solutions including building machine
learning models designing pipelines and
developing apis NLP Engineers typically
have a background in engineering or
computer science and have knowledge of
machine learning algorithms software
development and data structures the next
we have is text analytics specialist
this role involves analyzing large
amount of Text data to extract useful
information text analytics Specialists
typically have a background in data
analysis statistics and machine learning
and they use NLP tools and techniques to
process and analyze text Data language
model engineer this role involves
developing and improving natural
language processing models such as
language models and machine translation
models language model Engineers
typically have a background in computer
science machine learning and natural
language processing on number four we
have NLP researcher this role involves
conducting Research into new NLP methods
and techniques NLP researchers typically
have a background in computer science
machine learning and natural language
processing and they publish their
research in various academic journals
and conferences and the most awaited
let's start with salary of NLP Engineers
let us now discuss the salary of NLP
engineers in India and USA for the sake
of better understanding we will split up
the salary ranges based on the
experience level of a professional so
let's start with entry-level NLP
engineers in India the salary ranges
from 2.5 million rupees to 5 million
rupees however in U.S the salary ranges
between sixty thousand dollars to ninety
thousand dollars per year entry level
NLP Engineers typically have background
in computer science engineering or a
related field and have some experience
with NLP but may not have yet worked on
large-scale Enterprise projects moving
towards mid-level NLP Engineers these
Engineers earn 5 million to 8 million
rupees per year however in United States
they earn between 90 000 to 120 000 per
year mid-level NLP Engineers have few
years of experience working on NLP
projects and are typically comfortable
working on both Technical and business
related aspects of NLP projects they may
have some leadership responsibilities
and are often responsible for ensuring
that NLP projects are completed on time
and ospec next we have a senior level
NLP Engineers these Engineers earn up to
8 million rupees to 15 million rupees in
India per year however in United States
they earn between hundred and twenty
thousand dollars 265 000 per year
senior level NLP Engineers have
extensive experience working on
Enterprise level NLP projects and are
often considered authorities in NLP
Technologies methods and tools they may
serve as subject matter experts lead
teams of Engineers and other NLP
professionals and be responsible for
ensuring the long-term success of NLP
projects with that said NLP Engineers
are in high demand across many
Industries and their expertise in
understanding human language is crucial
to the development of advanced AI
application in this video we have taken
a look at the role of NLP Engineers the
types of jobs they can do and salary
range they can expect to succeed in this
field it is important to stay up to date
with the latest NLP techniques and
Technologies and to build a strong
foundation in computer science and
machine learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you